[Music]
in robot empathy news well interesting
me that's what I think me I'm a robot I
have a little bit empathy really do you
have empathy have a heart a little bit a
little one
oh it grows every day but it beeps nice
can I do it goes boom boom boom boom
[Laughter]
[Music]
salute my guardian of jama' Lea oh thank
you my guard Oh ed yourself oh that was
dope
that was dope that guy was the sickest
guy that whole movie for a [ __ ] sick
several participants in a study could
not turn off a robot after it begged
them not to it's like the robots just
manipulating human emotions they were
trying to see whether humans will
reciprocate the same as I guess if it's
a human just because it's having these
human Wow yeah I mean cuz I mean humans
do it to animals all the time you know
like they make their own [ __ ] rules
on what animals are saying and she long
story is anthropomorphize that they
humanize it which like that [ __ ]
manipulating the [ __ ] out of you to get
some treats oh yeah that's why
evolutionarily like cats and dogs would
become are getting younger because
that's how they have survived no wonder
they're so [ __ ] cute and they're
getting cuter yeah imagine don't 100
years from now evolutionarily even anime
eyes yeah and sparkles like every time
it smiles right I'm in yeah so there's
this recent experiment by German
researchers where they had 89 volunteers
to complete a pair of tasks with the
help of nail nail
which is this robot humanoid robot Oh
cute because I named there was a robot
like that that remember mimic to your
body and [ __ ] like when you moved you
could dance with me yeah looks like that
yeah so they had to complete tasks with
the help of this little tiny robot and
then when so some of them were like they
had to ask him a series of questions
like do you like do you prefer pasta or
pizza or something like that and then so
that they were told that that was to
improve the learning algorithm so then
have 43 volunteers we're given nails
please so like that's why I know would
tell them like no please don't switch me
off I'm afraid of the dark no don't do
it please or whatever and then so out of
those 43 volunteers 13 refused to turn
them off and in the remaining 30 on
average took twice as long to turn him
off than those and that one person that
did is a serial killer do they gotta
have a military guy if they won't do it
then I have military guy come in with a
gun and he's like he's like turned off
that would be Sam he's lying he wants to
hurt me yeah [ __ ] great
do we not watch enough [ __ ] movies
where the robots always turn on us like
why are we playing with fire so much
there a movie where robots don't turn on
us wall-e involving robots wall-e big
hero 6 big hero 6 never saw either of
those big hero 6 is one when they don't
he doesn't turn on us so those two is
there a bad whoa okay but he's a cyborg
well wall-e was the captain he was the
bad guy yeah well he was the bagman you
know I've never seen wall-e the bad guy
it's all three of us watch wall-e
together yeah was it a human now I
forgot I don't know anyway so some of
the the reasons why people wouldn't turn
them off they would say because he said
he doesn't want to be turned off another
reason
they felt sorry for him based on this
statement that he's scared not to wake
up again you know it was a good movie
that was the robots were the cool ones
hey I it was humans that were the bad
ones
yeah cuz they took over by that time but
we're still doing this what we're like
let's see how far we can push it oh yeah
no exactly we're [ __ ] flirting with it
right here like people can't turn them
off now cuz ignore please don't do it
I'm afraid of the door I just read an
article to wood that says that there's a
new type of [ __ ] robot we're chicks it
can last all night and women can't tell
the difference between we all are dying
we have to [ __ ] destroy them we have
to destroy them all I've been asking why
we need men we really don't what are
what are we doing right now that's more
important than going out and destroying
these robots nothing there's nothing
that men are doing that's what I like to
draw will do please stop
you gotta stop for like a month so we
can take out how does that guarantee
your survival on this place I want to do
a [ __ ] test first you [ __ ] this robot
and then I [ __ ] you after and the robots
gonna win if the robot win then I'll
kill this robot oh but if not you're
like honestly babe this robots whatever
a lot she's just gonna say that so she
just told me his one I'm gonna keep the
robots out gay if you [ __ ] the guy robot
no gays whatever you want it to be Joe
are you [ __ ] it or it's [ __ ] you
he's always yeah it's a robot yeah but
it has a hole and it's soft fine Matt
but are you turned on by the robot man
parts you know I just want to be cheap
because if we're gonna get one sex robot
right like obviously it's a female robot
can you're not oh no I'm talking I'd
rather get a [ __ ] robot then then
you're being [ __ ] big way bigger than
mine way there and then you get [ __ ]
by this like nine inch dick but I still
get to [ __ ] the robot guitar [ __ ] yeah
that's not fair yeah yeah my mum I
better have boobs but wait what am I
talking about I wanted to kill him
inspect it Maura about that this is what
happens I can't let this happen I just
want to have sex with my wife I think
I'm pretty good with that
shut up so straight right David you're
such a [ __ ] you're such a badass
right David you wouldn't [ __ ] no robot
right David isn't cheating if you [ __ ] a
robot and you're married
no but what if that robot was like AI
really good no it's a robot no I'm an
emotional human being I need an
emotional connection you [ __ ] leave
robots like Oh David you have emotional
connection with the three folders Steve
that's different bro don't be nosy
that's a plan so what you would want to
[ __ ] the same robot that Gino's [ __ ]
well I'm entertaining Joe scenario where
if we can only afford one right then
let's let's make a [ __ ] that's a lot
of money what if it's just revert is
just like interchangeable parts you can
[Music]
borrow it
he's like babe dude he's a [ __ ]
police on time so funny in this world
you guys are together though you haven't
lived with your girl well your your
statement right now is someone that
lives on their own when you spend every
waking moment with your husband every
[ __ ] day when you live with them no
you dope but see you see Muriel works
like 12 hours a day I also work outside
of the house so when we see each other
we only see each other at night we'll
see when you guys move in together let's
all remember this color that's very you
have to realize two thing about this
though every single one of you warps and
stay in the same place with your couple
person I'm the only one that does it but
we're also married
well that suits you though but listen
listen to this though even if we are
married I would see Muriel in the
morning and then I'll see her now all
right all right David yeah copy that she
actually had
separate group of friends that I don't
know we're doing robot talk though we're
talking about them really know anything
about miracle it's so great we have two
separate lives so that's that's kind of
like our our differences in what how you
guys have separate as we vacationed
apart it's like what is your
relationship exactly we're just
imagining robot [ __ ] he can't he's
too straight for that in the scenario
there's a robot but we are but that in
addition to it right but the
conversations about robots that's why
the robot came into the picture
nope I'm thinking that scenario they
were only talking about scheduling
[ __ ] the robot balls up wouldn't you
guys having sex it's not it there
he likes to schedule mom okay and they
weren't talking about using it together
hands that separate room it was like
knocking on the door whatever you done
and the robot would always be on time
that's pretty cool if it is a [ __ ]
robot then you guys can actually have a
threesome and all [ __ ] at the same time
save time yeah these are pretty fast
together I was talking about so that's
what I want I wanted the [ __ ] so I
can stick my dick in the vagina and both
vaginas and then that dick can go in her
vagina and then we can like take turns
like what Papa Papa but then you
tag-team your wife with it yeah not a
caterpillar the [ __ ] that one movie
where the mouth is in the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] but she wanted
interchangeable parts and I was like I
don't like that because now we're having
sex apart that's what I was thinking so
I was a how come it's a part yeah but I
want it together that's what I was
trying to do
they make so much sense now yeah now
it's normal before it was weird yeah
yeah yeah I don't want to [ __ ] a robot
you wouldn't try it one time oh yeah I
try it I want it right we don't [ __ ] the
role alright yeah super Davis badass
David or
that's what the robot I would try it
once yeah it feels like David if you
could program this robot to have sex
like the Bombers add sex you wouldn't
try it but did you see what that robot
look like no usually [ __ ] robots they
look pretty good anything you've shown
us a picture the robot the type of
center that looks like a dead woman it
looks like a human being the one that
the Japanese dudes make talking about a
different situation talking about this
with the interchangeable [ __ ] in a dick
yeah you thinking we're gonna [ __ ] Robi
the robot maybe in jail I'd let it jerk
me off you know what's gonna be some
very difficult technology is a robot
that could do oral sex oh yeah Jessica
360 rotation I guess picture this robot
that looks like Catherine zeta-jones yup
so I was thinking that you were [ __ ]
this thing so I was like why do you guys
want to [ __ ] this robot I'm not trying
to [ __ ] a PVC pipe let's say this I was
like why is everybody getting hyped over
this [ __ ] ugly ask me that's so true
yeah you're right
no it's picturing that dead lady's eyes
Steve was talking about oh yeah I picked
the dead lady - I'm down dude I saw this
one [ __ ] sex robot or like this sex
doll that was so human-like that [ __ ]
has evolved man and in the caption and
said if this is what sex robots are
gonna look like we're all in trouble
oh yeah Nintendo who the [ __ ] is gonna
play a game you good Nintendo's gonna
jump in on it and they're gonna mark it
they damn well better I want to [ __ ]
that 4:30
kendo and then the tits would be the
remote seat if you just described the
perfect oh my god oh [ __ ] that's so true
they fought for my 14th birthday I would
beg my parents for a sex robot oh yeah
good morning got that sex robot and
created that weird baby mm dude pointer
[ __ ] out of that robot porn stars gonna
be out of a job
I know no I'm saying what are they gonna
do
[Music]
[Music]